the signboards of a Jewish restaurant
smashed a pig head marked with a Star of
David dumped by a door swastikas and
Stars of David dog Donn a wall this was
the aftermath of an anti-semitic attack
in the Eastern German city of chemnitz
in August 2018 it was just one of more
than 1600 anti-semitic crimes committed
in Germany last year that's an increase
of 10% on 2017 particularly worrying the
number of violent incidents like this
one in Berlin has increased by two
thirds I am concerned but not really
surprised it fits with what I hear from
Jewish organizations and representatives
when I talk to them it should give us
the impetus to take preventive action
soon and to make sure that anti-semitism
does not arise in the first place
much of this hatred comes from far-right
supporters but experts say some of it
arrives from opposition to Israel
including from migrants from the Muslim
world and Germany is not alone
anti-semitic incidents are becoming more
common in other countries to France this
week reported a rise of more than 70% in
2018 compared with the previous year
unfortunately anti-semitism is on the
advance everywhere in Europe we need to
find European solutions I support the
idea of making the fight against
anti-semitism a priority for the German
EU Presidency next year another part of
the picture in Germany is that the
Jewish community is growing and
demonstrations of solidarity with them
by non-jews are common while most
Germans recognize that from the
Holocaust comes a special responsibility
to protect Jews there is sadly still a
minority ready to turn violent
aggression against them joining us in
the studio for more on all these
developments is anastasi Epps a Tokina
she chairs a Jewish student organization
here in Berlin and she also works for
other Jewish institutions in German
so SIA thanks so much for being with us
so I mean we just saw in this report
some pretty disturbing statistics
anti-semitic offenses on the rise in
Germany how does that make you feel
are you afraid actually afraid is not
the right term for me personally I think
that we already faced anti-semitic
thoughts and also deeds in in Germany
before but now we can target them and
now we can focus on what's happening and
that makes me feel strong actually that
now we we have tools to address this
problem so what about your personal
experience have you encountered any kind
of discrimination or even attack
personally yes for sure that was mostly
connected to anti-israel politics and
yeah that was pretty scary especially on
the streets when the demonstrations in
2014 started and that was a very scary
moment for me because I used to work in
a Jewish community and I was literally
afraid to step out of the building
because I didn't know what will happen
to me outside so yes for sure and can
you tell us a little bit more in detail
what happened what were people saying or
how are they behaving there was
screaming that Jews have to be gassed in
the chambers and that's the rhetoric we
are not used to or we can act definitely
to Holocaust rhetoric and that's
definitely very scary and could you
identify who were those people shouting
those slogans those slogans were
connected to a demonstration connected
to anti-israel demonstration connected
again to the Gaza war so actually it
wasn't something about Jews in Germany
but this which was very
Faust's all right well I also want to
ask you about your work within the
Jewish community I know you're active in
a number of different institutions and
organizations how important is it for
you to be visible in your work after
2014 it became more important to me
especially because I saw that this as I
said switch from anti-israel to
anti-semitic is very fast and actually
it in planes that's the same and I think
that that was the moment when I
personally understood that it's
important to invest more in the
education education and fight this well
speaking of education I really want to
ask you quickly if you can to explain to
us the work you do with the initiative
called rent a Jew it sounds very strange
it sounds very provocative and that's
exactly the goal it's an educational
program to give an opportunity to
educational institutions like schools to
meet real Jews because most of the main
population in Germany just heard about
Jewish society in Germany but never
spoke to any person from this community
and that brings people together and
develops a dialogue alright anastacio
plateau Gina thank you so very much for
being with us today thank you
you